my name is hannah and this is about the
dependent samples t-test by watching
this tutorial you will easily understand
what a dependent samples t-test is
how you can calculate and interpret it
and what the requirements are and at the
end of this video i will show you how
you can easily calculate this t-test
online with data type if you want to
look up the topics of this video just
take a look at datadept.net
there you will find all the informations
so let's get started
the t-test for dependent samples tests
whether the mean value of two dependent
samples
significantly differ from each other
what is a dependent sample
in the case of dependent samples
the measured values are away level in
pairs the pairs result for example by
measurement repetitions with the same
persons
let's look at an example
let's say you want to find out if
vacations have an influence on the
stress level of people
in order to analyze this question you
have created a small online
questionnaire with datatab.net
by using this questionnaire
you ask people before and after their
vacation about their stress level
there are now two ways to do this
possibility one is you interview a group
of people before they go on vacation
and then you ask an other group of
people
after they come back from a vacation
in this case you would have an
independent sample because the people
you interviewed before the vacation
have nothing to do with the people you
interviewed after the vacation
the second possibility and also the
better possibility is you ask people
before they go on vacation and then you
ask the exactly same group of people
again
when they return from their vacation
in this case you would have a dependent
sample so the measured values are always
available in pairs so you have two
values for exactly the same person
so therefore if the people have nothing
in common with each other you have an
independent sample
if the people you ask before and after
are exactly the same people
the measurements are in pairs and you
have a dependent sample
in this case the t-test for dependent
samples is used
before you can calculate a t-test of
course you must formulate your
hypotheses
in the case of the dependent t test the
null hypothesis is
there is no significant difference
between the means of the two dependent
groups
and your alternative hypothesis would be
there is a significant difference
between the means of the two dependent
groups
therefore
one hypothesis is that there is no
difference and the other hypothesis says
that there is a difference
of course it's also possible to
formulate directed or one-sided
hypotheses
then the null hypothesis would be
one sample has a significantly smaller
or equal mean value
and the alternative hypothesis would be
one sample has a significantly larger
mean value
of course the smaller and larger can
also be reversed depending on your
research question
how does the dependency test work
of course we'll look at this using an
example to recap the dependent samples
t-test tests whether the means of two
dependent samples are significantly
different from each other
let's say you want to test whether a
diet program developed by a celebrity
really has an effect on people's weight
to do this you find individuals who are
willing to follow the diet program
you measure the weight of the test
persons once before and once after the
diet program
since you measure the weight of the test
persons once before and once after the
diet program the measured values are
always in pairs and that's why you have
a dependent sample
your null hypothesis is the diet program
has no significant effect on the body
weight of the participants
and your alternative hypothesis is the
diet program has a significant effect
on the body weight of participants
of course you could also make directed
hypotheses
your alternative hypothesis then would
either be
the diet program significantly reduces
the weight
or the diet program significantly
increases the weight of the individuals
but enough about these hypotheses
how do we calculate the t-test for
independent samples
first you start by weighing each test
person once before and once after the
completed diet program
we are not interested in the weight
before and after but we are interested
in the difference between before and
after
so for example how much a person has
gained or lost weight
therefore we calculate the difference
between before and after for each person
by doing this we have converted the two
paired values into
one new value
by this conversion we have made one data
set out of the two data sets
now that we only have one data set
the t-test for dependent sample is
equivalent to the t-test for one sample
let's say the first person gained three
kilos the second lost four kilos the
third one lost seven kilos and the
fourth person
gained five kilos
so on average the participants lost
0.75 kilos
now the big question is whether the diet
is responsible for the fact that there
is a difference or whether this
difference occurred by chance
and the diet has actually no influence
to answer this question you now need the
t-test for dependent samples
now some of you will certainly shout
stop what about the requirements don't
we have to check them first that is
absolutely correct however first i would
like to explain the basics to you by
using an example and then we will go
into the requirements
to calculate the t-test there are now
two possibilities either you calculate
the t value by hand and compare it with
the so-called critical t value
we will look at this in a moment
or the second way is you simply use a
statistic software as data tab and let
it calculate and interpret everything
automatically i will show you how to do
this online at the end of this video so
let's start with the calculation by hand
we want to calculate the t test but how
do we get to the t value
in order to calculate the t value
we first need the number of cases
we have four dependent pairs so we have
four cases
the number of degrees of freedom is the
number of cases minus one which makes
three
we calculate the mean of the data simply
by adding up all the values and dividing
them by the number of cases this leads
us to the mean value of minus
0.75
kilos
next thing we need is the standard
deviation
for this data we get a standard
deviation of 5.84
by using the standard deviation and the
number of cases we can now calculate the
standard error of mean which is
2.84
the standard error of mean tells us how
much the mean would vary
if we had taken quite a lot of samples
this means that the larger this value is
the more likely a large weight gain or
loss will occur by chance because there
is simply a large variation in the mean
so and now we can finally calculate the
t value the t value is the mean
minus 0 divided by the standard arrow of
the mean
y zero
our null hypothesis says that there is
no difference
so we want to test if the mean is
significantly different from zero
now we need to check whether the amount
of this calculated t value is smaller or
larger than the so called critical t
value we can find the critical t value
in a table but how does this work
we have set a significance level of five
percent
if we are testing an undirected
hypothesis this would mean that we split
the five percent between the left and
the right side
so we have 2.5 on the left
and 2.5
on the right side
therefore in the table of critical t
values we need to look at
97.5 percent this is what we get by
subtracting half the significance level
from one
so we are in this column right now
the degrees of freedom in our case are
five minus one which makes three so we
are in the table in this row so the
critical t value is 3.182
we've calculated the t value of minus
0.26 therefore the critical t value is
greater than the amount of the t value
that we have calculated
if the magnitude of the calculated t
value is less than the critical t value
the null hypothesis is maintained
the table with the critical t values can
be found on datadept.net
and you find the link below in the video
description
our null hypothesis is the diet program
has no effect and the alternative
hypothesis is
the diet program has an effect on the
body weight
our calculated t value was smaller than
the critical t value therefore based on
these data we retain the null hypothesis
and assume that the diet program has no
effect on body weight
so let's start with the first assumption
now
there are two dependent groups or
samples
as the name theta's for dependent sample
suggests
the groups must be dependent for example
a value of one group must belong to a
value of the other group
the condition is fulfilled for example
if the weight of one and the same person
is measured before and after a diet
program
however it's not fulfilled if the weight
is measured from persons who have dieted
and from other person who have not
dieted and the persons are not related
to each other
assumption two is that the variables
must be metric
in the t test for the abandoned samples
the difference of the two dependent
values is calculated and then we
calculate the mean
of course this only makes sense if our
values have a metric scale level
a metric variable for example is a
person's salary
a non-metric variable would be
a person's educational attainment
let's look at the third assumption now
the third assumption assumes that the
differences of the paired values are
normally distributed
so this means that the differences
between the paired values required for
the pair t-test must be normally
distributed
it could for example be that the weight
of different people has a normal
distribution
an example for no normal distribution
would be the difference of the number of
eyes after throwing two dices
and now i will explain to you the second
way which is how you can calculate it
online with data tab in order to do this
just google data tab click on the
statistics calculator and copy your own
data into this table
then select this tab and click on the
variables you want to analyze
data that recognizes that there are
dependent samples and automatically
calculates a t-test for dependent
samples
you can also choose whether you want to
test an undirected or a directed
hypothesis
further datadeb gives you the hypotheses
and if you scroll down you get the
results
here you can read the p-value if the
p-value is smaller than your defined
significance level for example five
percent
then the null hypothesis is rejected
based on the available data in this case
the p-value is 0.197
which is greater than 0.05
therefore the null hypothesis is
retained
furthermore you can also check the
assumptions and get an interpretation in
words
the score before vacation had lower
values than the score after vacation
a dependent sample status showed that
this difference was not statistically
significant
this results in a p-value of 0.197
which is above the established
significance level of 0.05
therefore the theta's result is not
significant and the null hypothesis is
maintained
this means that it is assumed that both
samples are from the same population
i hope you enjoyed the video if you like
just try data dab it's very easy to use
bye and see you next time
me